fin des années 50 début des années 60
des bandes rivales sèment la terreur ce
sont les blousons noirs la presse les a
baptisés ainsi elles étaient 59 à cause
de leur look moyenne d'âge 17 ans
agressions vols en tout genre x les
journaux de toute la france racontent
leurs méfaits
à la télévision les journalistes
prennent un autre parti ils vont
rencontrer ces blousons noirs pour les
comprendre
en 1962 le magazine l'avenir est à vous
s'invitent au square saint lambert à
paris
fief d'une bande emblématique pour
battait ou quoi
ce pari sérieusement mais quelle est la
réaction de la police quand il ya des
histoires comme ça quand l attachement
développe h moulin et conques
ce goût de la castagne un autre jeune le
raconte
quelques minutes plus tard j'avais déjà
fait des bêtises dans sa rue qu'est ce
qu'ils appellent un gland bêtises on
peut tout quoi je me suis battu
on est en géant j'ai insulté des
personnes
et pourquoi vous faisiez comme ça quand
ça tombe pour me rendre intelligent quoi
faire le garçon qui se prend deux points
4 il y a aussi une quête de virilité et
l'effet de bande qui galvanise ses
jeunes souvent issus de classe ouvrière
la délinquance est pour eux un moyen de
tuer le temps les blousons noirs sont
plus voyous gangsters ils se sentent
laissés pour compte puisque déjà et a
déjà voulu dire comme julian façon
durant à l'agent commissaire la société
nous mêmes pour les jeunes y en a qui
les aurait mis en a qui les gêne pas ils
brandissent une haine des flics et de la
bourgeoisie mais pas de revendications
claires pour autant ces pilules
le chef de la bande des batignolles
qu'ils l'expliquent en 1960 john howett
politique qui veut dire que vous n'avez
pas l'opinion bien que romain les wagons
les opinions et les gares pour quoi tu
vas pas personnellement nous en ait pas
ricard est bien déconner je préfère des
intérêts politiques et fait de beaux
rendez sentiment d'ennui et de rejet si
le phénomène des blousons noirs s'est
dissipée dans les années 60
ce sont les mêmes circonstances qui
touche encore aujourd'hui certains gènes
[Musique]